welcome to this video Tsubasa is the
opponent so hard Subala really okay it's
an i am poland what do we get nims oh
someone recently said i should play this
image again a little bit more in the
Newman's Own maybe we get a new so here
yeah the zimage saw is fun it's kind of
a leading to crazy positions quite often
so let's go for that check not only be
six years not cancelled yet that's kind
of helpful for black uh huh interesting
okay let's put this here and then d5 if
I would have played d5 immediately might
have had a farm I don't know let's see
Wow yeah okay yeah left something that
you can do yeah absolutely transposing
to some kind of iqp position mmhmm yeah
f 393 looks a bit strange am
and Joe that's not great what can you do
I totally underestimated what he did
here this capturing and so on it's
really quite okay so let's do this kappa
c 5 i'm not sure if you can rely that's
helpful that's just the lemon move
Queenie so now you have to play Moxie 8
or something like that this is
immediately needing to trouble I think
okay what is allowing this or the tempo
why okay he's just blundering is Queen
yeah I don't get it if he goes to g5 I
can go back to what sorry sorry for my
surprise yeah I don't get it this queen
is strapped Queen h5 g4 Queen g 6 97 and
over it's like
yeah I mean he said his something from
Japan maybe this is some kind of
Japanese suicide sword ritual or
something queen is just trapped black
resigned well that was quick from a
somewhat questionable position to a 22 a
win okay the engine actually gives white
pretty big advantage why exactly huh
quite surprised here I thought black
would be okay but may be okay if he does
not get this see pawn I mean I'm in good
shape that's true but I thought I might
drop it somehow this this okay quick
Queenie 7 is completely wrong but the
thoughts let's say rook c8 for example
yeah look be one that was my plan we
should back Quincy to this is what I
thought but I wasn't sure about this but
it is a good position right hmm he
simply doesn't get the pawn and if I'm
getting like one or two coordination
moves Bishop 2d 495 black is basically
falling apart them yeah okay I really
had my doubts but ok this is this is
completely suicide Liam now we can go
back but what kind of position is that
you nokia for c6 the engine gives this
move is also nice threatening this and
this and over thank you and the queen is
just trapped Queen jus 6 197 and I can I
have a nice choice I can't capture with
both pieces okay it was fun okay thanks
for watching